all right caro-kann just go with the
exchange variation now let's try the
mainline mainline caro-kann and all
right so far so book how lengthy is this
particular line each for looking to trap
that Bishop Knight after three looking
to get to e5 with tempo on the bishop
and now I could get that mmm I think
this is a mistake
pretty sure you're supposed to do ninety
seven to prevent Knight e5 with temple
on this Bishop what's the follow-up
going to be hmm seems like it's the
right thing to do Knight loves that
central post and now it gets there with
tempo has to come back and I could be
pinpointing this pawn with Bishop c4 but
I think there's a convenient reply
Black's going to be doing this move
anyhow
so what am I getting at am I getting
that there
see three yeah see three I'm being a I
guess a little bit sneaky I'm looking
for Queen B 3 hitting at f7 and b7 might
be something to that like if Knight d7 I
think I could still play here mmm
this threatens mate and b7 if after
Queen b3 Knight takes pawn takes the
knight has to move and then as a
follow-up I can take this pawn or maybe
even just go with the positional move
something like e6 I think I like that
idea
Queen b3 this diagonal has some of my
attention in particular d3 since if
there is this Knight capture and I'm
recapturing it's both the bishop and
Queen that are converging on that square
so my eye tends to gravitate towards
squares where are my opponent's pieces
where where my opponent has two or more
pieces that can go to a particular
square those tend to be good moves just
in general because the that's really the
implications of that is that you're
staying coordinated and that's usually a
very good thing to be doing
staying coordinated avoids what you just
keep running with that logic staying
coordinated avoids your opponent getting
potential tactics against you so what
about a six
Queen takes b7 or e6 take this punim on
this guy I think I just like that right
away have black defend this first and if
I really want to do that next then do it
it's gonna be some issue on this square
only if the Queen comes out to a5 would
that be maybe a potential threat
sacrificing on c3 other than that I'm
just not seeing it I think this is a
fine pawn to take it's not just a pawn
grab it's a pawn grab that is now coming
with another serious threat very serious
throughout taking this pawn forcing
Queen bumping up and then I
ruk so that is a very easy mistake to
make the knight f6 not recognizing that
95 would be coming with tempo it's
something that I've done before in one
of the many blitz games that I've played
online I am fine with the kleenex change
I am up upon and I guess I could follow
up with what where does my Bishop belong
86 with tempo what else where does my
king want to go where does he want to go
Bishop d2 and then queenside castle I
know that this rook is probably just
going to stay here for just a little bit
it's gonna come back over I don't want
to give back that pawn let me just go
Bishop d2 maybe the other thing behind
this is that I want to kick this night
away I think I want to also get rid of
that Bishop
I think it's blacks best piece
you know I'm gonna do this it seems like
this is coming at a snail's pace right
now this idea but I'm looking for e 2 F
3 and then e 4 I want to exchange light
square bishop s' I see that this guy
right here is really the best piece
right now for black so I'm looking to
remove it all so now that the position
is going to simplify a bit more I might
as well being pre-move mode without
seeing how it's going to simplify that
more maybe castling is not needed and
I'm not going to Castle I'm just gonna
run with b3 if a 5 maybe I should have
considered that I move earlier or
something I should have kicked that
night out the first opportunity I had I
don't know when I did do Bishop d2 there
was ecigs and then if I played c4 the
night could still be making use of that
square so really I just don't want the
night to get to be for all together
kingi to I think is where I want my king
to reside instead of castling he's just
gonna camp out on that e to square light
square these guys are gonna be off
there's no way to really avoid that g6
would just be imprisoning that Bishop so
ok it's opening up a little bit more but
I'm not too concerned about that if the
knight takes maybe I can do a pawn grab
oh we're doing that and now I'm gonna
take with the check because now I have a
convenient way to be defending against
this poem you could play to e4 hit the
Bishop and defense e3 centralizing the
knight and this right here is a very
reliable home for this guy cannot be
kicked away by any black pawns and with
the bishop still in f6 I had
possibilities with Knight g5 taking with
the check and then hitting the bishop
I'm looking to really do what here I'm
looking to just simplify as much as I
can
let's keep this night constrained this
night can't be attacked with the rook
okay I didn't know that I was gonna come
up
oh there's pressure on this pawn three
times but my king is hitting that rook
so there's no time to really grab that
how do i entangle myself how do I make
forward progress I think I make forward
progress by kicking this night away and
I think that is uh
coming up very soon oh I think there was
a possibility for a knight F no Knight
f6 wouldn't have been the greatest now
oh we got we are gonna have Knight f6
and what I'm gonna have a role reversal
soon if we have the exchange of knights
it's then going to be my bishop that I
devote such as right now to the defense
of f2 so now that everything is strung
together my rook is no longer needed on
c1 that's that's for sure
he's only there to support upon that's
on c3 no longer the case the rook now
belongs on d1 actually why not this rook
I don't have a good answer for that
should probably be this one looking for
the seventh and I could actually just
start marching these pawns right March
him he is a passed pawn I really I'm I I
don't want to play a three because I
just see that as a target for this this
dark square bishop I'm gonna keep my
pawns on light it's best I can keep
pushing and then this is this pond could
really come a far away on b6 this Bishop
watching over it two steps away wait a
second I could have just taken the
bishop I could just taken that Bishop -
yeah let's just do that
let's just not take free pieces that's
what I said right there let's not take
free pieces this is this is a wonderful
start it's a wonderful start here let's
not take free pieces I said
I could do that now I could do that
how funny how funny is that huh funny
for you not for me oh man I can see you
to move combo but when it comes to the
one move combos they're tough
apparently okay let's get this pond
rolling there's no way to disrupt this
structure I can't do anything the ponds
are past past pond pac-man mode gobble
up pieces design time reason time okay
good game QWERTY let's back up my quick
point to really make from this mainline
Caro so far everything is fine right
here I don't know if I was able to I
don't know if I should have gotten the
advantage that I did from playing 95 but
just know you should not allow a knight
to centralize itself with tempo on the
bishop so that's why this move order is
important here so it's the Knight d7
move that you'll have to run forward
with this is not the only time by the
way that there was a move order issue
out of the caro-kann while I was
streaming there's another one out of I
think it's the two Knights defense of
the Caro
if black isn't careful it could get very
difficult for black and if if white
makes these accurate moves then there's
really just not a good defense so this
is an in charge something that certainly
steer clear of develop this Knight your
queen night to watch over 'if I've don't
let that tempo come in there instead of
Knight d7 here's the other thing
douwe 6 so that when I play Queen b3
I'm not hitting at both targets 97
doesn't address f7 or b7 so I'm gonna
I'm gonna be struggling much more or
it's gonna be much more difficult
to get an advantage or a clear advantage
if you're playing east six right here so
another move order issue instead of
ninety seven looking to e6 because this
is my intent with c3 to support my
Center and make use of b3 hitting at b7
which is the one square that is weekend
right as soon as you move about with
that light square bishop and transfer it
to the Kings side right and transfer
that Queen side Bishop two now a king
side piece that's my main point because
right here I am now going to just be up
a pawn and the Queen's off the board I
don't know that I gave you a way out
from here more exchanges occur my
Knights in a central post my Kings in a
center post more trades are just
favouring me in all cases and I should
take a free piece if it's there but I
was too excited about just pushing my
pawn but that's the main point main
point 97 right here instead of this
Knight move and ecigs right here instead
of the 97th move okay good game